Scott schuman,
the sartorialist what made me want to
work in fashion when I was growing up,
I played sports like all the regular
kids in the Midwest,
boys in the Midwest and a would read
sports illustrated and you know,
read all that,
all the athletes that I liked and kept
reading that,
what they were spending their money on
cars and music and fashion.
And so I'd start picking up those
magazines and like,
um,
I ended up becoming more interested in
fashion than I did sports,
you know,
and the better I addressed the more
attention they seem to get from women,
which was more attention than what I was
getting on the football field.
Blogging part was pretty easy.
You know,
I had an idea for the Sartorialist,
this idea of mixing photographs of guys
that I knew were stylish with guys that
I knew were fashionable,
which are two different things.
Um,
but I only really knew about websites at
that time and I knew that a website
would take too much time,
too many other people would have to be
involved.
And,
uh,
when I happened to be going through the
Internet,
I found a blog just happened to click
onto a blog and I'm the kind of person
that once I see something interesting,
I just started hitting all the buttons
trying to figure out how they're doing
it.
And it was an interior design blog
actually.
And uh,
I thought it was pretty cool.
She had like 30 comments,
you know,
she had some good visuals up and once I
saw that I was able to look at it in an
abstract enough way to be able to say,
you know,
I could do this with my photographs,
that once I figured out how she was
doing it and how simple it was to do,
I thought,
you know,
that's the format I want to do.
You know,
there weren't really any,
um,
kind of definitely I don't think any
street style blogs maybe face hunter was
right about that time.
But I didn't really know it in the
beginning.
But I saw the potential of using,
you know,
a blog as a,
as a visual format as opposed to with
just text driven.
At least I think most of the blogs at
that time were very text driven.
If they had a little bit of visual,
it wasn't very important where for me I
thought,
you know,
this would be a great way to put
photographs up and then,
and then put a little bit of text to
create a conversation.
But I'm,
the simplicity is what made the blogging
part.
So the simplicity and the interaction
with the audience,
with the two things I think made it most
attractive.
The difference between what's designers
create or,
you know,
they're creating a little world every
season,
you know,
head to toe a full look,
a head shoes,
bags,
dresses,
the whole thing more street fashion is,
you know,
what people were really wearing.
You know,
there's an element of new,
there's an element of previous seasons.
There's um,
your own history,
you know,
your sweatshirt from highschool and a
vintage pieces.
And you know,
it's that kind of combination that I
find so much more interesting than just
the runway.
Right.
You know,
and I love fashion.
I love going to the runway shows.
It's not so much,
um,
for me a shopping trip is,
it is the appreciation of the craft of
these,
you know,
um,
design geniuses,
you know,
who come up with beautiful color
combinations and beautiful proportion,
um,
suggestions and these kinds of ideas.
Right.
I look at the runway shows in a very
different way.
Just kind of a,
I'm a romantic,
uh,
artistic interpretation of how they
would like to see fashion going forward.
But for me it's much more abstract of
runways shows are much more abstract
than,
you know,
what ends up on people as much more real
to me.
Uh,
oh.
Realistically a fashion insider.
I mean,
I was in the business 15 years before I
started the blog,
so,
you know,
even though it was in a different part
of the business,
it was in sales and marketing.
Now the people that I've met since I've
been doing the blog did I know really
beforehand,
but I knew about the business,
you know,
and I,
that's how I really came up with the.
I,
you know,
I think part of what I do is the
photography.
I think that's half of it.
And like I'm able to,
I learned how to be able to shoot
something in the romantic way that I see
it.
Um,
but then the other half of it is the
editing,
you know,
who I choose to shoot and not so much
because of the drama and over
overdramatic nature of the way they're
dressed.
Sometimes it's very,
very subtle,
you know,
my background and tailoring and pattern
making and pattern making.
And uh,
I think really helped me understand,
you know,
the subtleties of a suits,
and why a guy can look great looking
very subtle in a suit.
And I think that's what really separates
me is um,
you know,
I have a real understanding of actual
clothes and how they work and how they
should fit and you know,
a reasonably good artistic version of
photography that kind of captures that.
And I think,
um,
that was really the kind of the best
combination,
a different screen fashion and style is
a fashion is,
is the,
sometimes,
you know,
it's the thing that's happening at that
moment.
You know,
sometimes it might be point issue,
sometimes it might be heels,
sometimes it might be flats,
where style I think is something that's
always there in your own personal
wardrobe,
whether it's a Navy Cardigan,
uh,
reading glasses like this.
Um,
but that's different for everybody.
You know,
everybody's version of style is totally
different and you know,
that's what I think keeps me going out
on the street every day is going out and
kind of seeing the variations and what
things maybe I had never seen in quite
that way that I find very curious in how
people will,
um,
be able to communicate their own persona
through their clothing,
their posture,
the way they wear their hair.
Uh,
you know,
I think all those elements end up
becoming very interesting because I
don't think I'm really particularly a
people person.
Um,
so for me,
I think it's interesting to kind of be
able to read people in that way.
Uh,
my favorite cities to shoot a Milan in
Italy obviously.
Uh,
the guys look great.
The women look great.
There's an old school romance.
I mean,
it feels like Italy in the 19 fifties,
you know,
the guys at the,
at the bar still were beautiful white
dinner jackets and uh,
you know,
there's a formality there.
I mean,
it doesn't matter if it's 90 degrees in
the summer,
uh,
and it's,
you know,
killer hot and in Milan and the guy
still put on their jackets to leave
their office to go get lunch and bring
it back to the office.
You'd never see that in America.
Guys barely can put on their,
you know,
their shirts to go to the office or,
keep their tie done.
Um,
so I think there's a romance,
you know,
that they're willing to um,
and enjoy that formality that they've
created.
They're in Milan and,
you know,
all across Italy,
but especially in Milan.
So I love that formality.
But at the same time,
after about a week that I've had enough
of that and I'm ready to go to Paris
where it's more sexy and more,
um,
a more dramatic,
more challenge,
you know,
in terms of how they put things
together.
Uh,
and then back to America.
I really love being able to go to those
three different places and you know,
in America were so much more sporty,
so much more color,
so much more,
so much more difference in the way that
we talk about our style and way we exude
our style.
We have in,
like in Milan for instance,
for example,
they're very narrow,
you know,
they,
everybody dresses in a few certain ways
and they have beautiful variations on
those few kind of styles.
But in America there's million different
styles,
know rocker and vintage and sporty and
preppy.
And so I like that variation.
So one without the other is not nearly
as interesting.
I've been to Hong Kong,
which I thought was very interested in
Beijing.
Um,
but I wanted to go there more and 2010
and that's one of my big challenges is
try and make it through Asia more.
And I don't know.
I'm curious to see what I find you.
I think,
uh,
in Japan I think,
you know,
there's a lot of style and love
subcultures,
but uh,
it'll be interesting to see how much of
them,
how much of the people wearing those
clothes are really expressing something
about who they are or who they want to
be.
And it will be very interesting to see
once,
especially once you get there,
once you get to a certain city,
like in Stockholm,
you really get to know the people a
little bit and what they're saying
through their clothes.
You want some more.
To me,
I think it's much more interesting than
just the clothes they're wearing or the,
the length of the skirt.
You start to understand something about
that culture,
you know,
in Rio,
none of the girls have short hair.
A lot of the interviews I did in Rio,
people say,
what do you want to find in Rio?
And say the one girl with short hair
because they just don't do it.
And once you get to know them a little
bit,
you realize that all the girls are
afraid to cut their hair short because
they're afraid they're men won't like
them.
So what you think of is a beautiful
natural style actually becomes a style
out of fear and it kinda changes your
perception of it a little bit.
So I'm a or for,
I'm Japan,
I'm very curious to see who is really
doing something unique and who's just
doing something because they've heard
that's the way they do it in Florence
and Milan.
Well,
by that question,
that's a,
what's that an oxymoron?
Trend in classic.
I don't know if we can put those two
together.
Um,
I don't know because it's totally
different for everybody.
You know,
for me,
uh,
a Navy Cardigan,
you know,
always looks great.
Um,
converse tennis shoes,
you know,
just always worked.
But that's for me.
Um,
and that's just,
at least for me,
I don't ever really look for trends.
I'm looking for just what captures my
attention at that time.
And rarely do I ever look back and try
and put together trends or say,
you know,
this kind of trend is important for me.
It's about the individual expression.
And if you go back and look through the,
uh,
through the archives,
you know,
you might find certain things become
trends,
but it's just not something that
particularly interests me.
Blog took off pretty quickly.
And,
uh,
I think it's because I had a particular
point of view,
you know,
there's been other street style
photographers,
Bill Cunningham and the New York Times,
you know,
it was like the godfather of modern
street style photography and other
people historically.
But I think what,
what they had always done was they were
always trying to,
to find the most dramatic,
the people that you wouldn't see every
day.
The people that were really different,
uh,
where I shot things that people would
aspire to,
something that maybe they would see
every day but didn't really know the
difference between something done well
and something not done as well as suit
that fits a guy really well as opposed
to just another suit or dress the,
oh,
that,
that fits a woman beautifully.
Or the way that she's put this
combination of,
you know,
uh,
for an open toe shoe.
You know,
two totally separate kind of ideas.
And yet she's put them together in a way
and you go,
oh,
okay,
that does look really great.
Um,
so I think it took off now because I was
shooting the incredibly different.
But because I was shooting something
people could relate to a lot of
different people could relate to.
And uh,
I don't think there was one time,
one particular thing that made me say,
you know,
this is really becoming popular.
But for me it was,
um,
you know,
these really heartfelt emails that we
get from people that,
uh,
you know,
that meant something to them that they
could look at these pictures and say,
you know,
I look like that guy,
but I don't look like him yet,
you know,
I want to look like him.
I'm big like,
Hey,
I'm a little chubby like him,
but he looks great and he's dressed
better in his clothes than I am.
So I know these guys were printing these
photographs up and taken it to Nordstrom
or saks or dillard's or wherever and
saying,
help me look like this and would be able
to achieve it because it was never in my
blog.
About how expensive it is,
you know,
I'm almost,
if you look at most of the guys that are
really well dressed,
it's just the attention to detail and
anybody can do that,
you know,
that just taking it to alterations in
getting the right amount of cuff and all
these little things that aren't about
the expense but just not the attention
to detail.
I think uh,
economic situation is affected in the
sense that,
you know,
a lot of people that have money always
have money and they're still buying and
they're still shopping.
They're just not talking about it when
we go to,
when I go to fashion week,
you know,
people are still wearing new things and
they're still shopping.
But I think they feel a little more
guilty when they've had to left five
people go from the company and not bring
to people that usually go to Europe,
to Europe.
So they're still shopping,
they're just not talking about it that
much.
Um,
but it's also,
I think,
helped people find a romance in shopping
in their own closet.
Again,
you know,
going back and looking at the clothes
they already have.
Because we've become so such consumers,
they think people kind of forget,
you know,
what,
what humongous closets we have full,
more close than what they could ever
wear.
So like maybe,
you know,
open people's eyes again,
it's really looking at what they have
and kind of re engineering it and
reworking it.
And I think that's good.
No,
it was in the business for 15 years.
My ex wife was a designer.
I had to show room where I worked with
young designers,
so I was very familiar with what
designers look for when they're going
out to look for inspiration and they're
not looking for trends,
you know,
if it's something that's already out on
the street now that's a trend now.
It's not going to be something they're
going to design for a year from now.
It's usually much more abstract.
And it might be a detail,
it might be color combination.
It could be even the way that the
posture of a girl,
you know,
I think one of the things that a lot of
designers look at my site is a,
not specifically the pieces that I'm
shooting,
but I think they may be looking at a
girl and think,
ah,
you know,
I love the way that girl looks and,
but I would never dress like that,
you know,
that girl inspires me.
But,
uh,
I love the idea of a long dress.
Maybe she was wearing a long dress and
they're thinking,
oh,
you know,
it's been a long time since I've
designed a long dress,
but I would never put it in a floral
print.
I would do it this way.
So I don't think they're looking at my
site for specific inspiration.
Like they're looking at an abstract way
to get them thinking about that customer
and that girl and that kind of girl that
would like to dress and how they would
do it a little bit differently.
And,
uh,
so I think that's probably the most
realistic.
Or even the guys,
you know,
I know a lot of the designers take a lot
of those old guy pictures.
I take these kind of really stylish old
guys and I know it's not because of the
specifics clothes that they're wearing,
but it's the posture and it's the
attitude and it's the elegance of these
guys that is attracting them,
that inspires them.
And it's the same thing for me.
You know,
I'm totally inspired.
It's not that I want to dress like an 80
year old Milanesa guy,
but,
uh,
the fact that they can still carry
themselves with such a,
um,
such,
uh,
an elegance even at that age I think is
very inspiring and whether it's Milan
or,
or Harlem or wherever,
I think that's something that guys
really key on a lot of the designers
key.
And on a,
when I'm shooting,
I try and keep it just very easy,
very unplanned.
You know,
I'm just walking around on the street
looking for somebody that uh,
um,
I think it looks cool and then it might
be able to get a good shot.
Today I was at Jamba juice and uh,
it was a very cool girl and I'm very
cool,
a young college girl and you know,
she had great coat and a little again
with a port trim and another print dress
and you know,
nothing that she was wearing was
expensive.
It was all kind of thrown together but
don't together just right,
you know,
the color combination.
How cute she looked.
She was very kind of charming.
Even though she was a tall girl,
she had a very kind of small persona,
very kind of shy persona.
And all of that's important.
I mean,
to me,
the persona that she's creating,
whether it's a big dramatic one or quiet
shy one,
I'm the way they stand.
All of that is something that you want
to try and capture in some way.
At least my perception of who that
person is in the photograph.
And uh,
so that's,
you know,
you never know where you're going to
meet these people.
That's why it's fun,
you know,
that's why I enjoy going out and getting
lost,
you know,
hopefully every day or every other day
and just seeing what's out there because
by the end of the day I usually get back
to my office and think,
Oh,
I never would've thought I'd run into
that kind of person.
They are doing that thing.
And uh,
by constantly challenging myself,
that's why I think keeps the integrity
and the sincerity of the blog.
Now.
I haven't had too many people.
I mean people turn me down,
but I think I've gotten pretty good at
being able to tell who will probably
turned me down,
you know,
and being able to read people a little
bit,
you know,
if someone's walking really fast and it
looks like they probably have some where
they're going.
So don't get too many people that are
upset.
Um,
I did have someone who was in the
background of one of my pictures that I
put up like two weeks ago and it totally
unrelated,
just happened to be walking by on the
street,
but he just happened to be looking just
at the right moment at the subject I was
taking a picture of.
And so email me today a feeling that
maybe he should be compensated for being
in that picture and,
and,
uh,
or at least a big print or something
like that.
So I thought that was a little bit odd.
Um,
but,
uh,
lot too many,
too many weird or bad stories.
I haven't been beaten up or chased or
anything yet.
A Guy Ron story,
a dot for,
uh,
not just because she's my girlfriend,
but I do truly think that she's got the
best women's fashion blog in the world.
Um,
her point of view is great.
You know,
she's,
um,
her writing is great,
photography is Great.
Her,
um,
the way that she communicates to her
reader is brilliant.
The way she writes and the ability to be
that stylish and that fashionable and
yet that approachable.
Uh,
it's a real challenge,
you know,
to be able to do that and do it
consistently every day because you can't
fake it.
She's doing a lot of things that other
blogs just aren't doing,
you know,
graphically.
Um,
that make it really interesting.
I mean,
my blogs doing very well at my audience
is bigger than hers,
but there are days when I look at her
blog and I'm totally jealous,
totally pissed that she hasn't told me
how she did some of those things that,
you know,
just little technical things to make a
shots look great or you know,
how she's laying them out on the page or
whatever.
So,
I mean,
it's a good kind of challenging
relationship,
but I think she probably does better
than anybody else right now.
And I hate her for that.
I don't know,
I guess,
uh,
with magazines,
I've never really looked at them that
way,
you know,
being someone who,
I'm a self taught photographer and I
taught myself photography,
just looking,
looking,
looking at the magazines.
So,
to be honest,
a lot of them,
you know,
I hardly ever read,
you don't really look at their,
what their real fashion opinion is.
Um,
for me it's always been very abstract,
you know,
so,
um,
I don't know,
I can't really,
I love my fashion magazines,
you know,
a lot of times I get a question,
do you think blogs will replace fashion
magazines?
And I hope not because I love my Gq and
vogue in Paris vogue and all of that.
Like I look at them less now just
because I've started to develop my own
photographic style that I'm very
comfortable with.
But uh,
uh,
they really are the ones that taught me
a,
the idea of how I wanted to shoot.
Well,
and it almost everyone in Hollywood,
uh,
almost everyone in the record business.
Um,
I don't know,
you know,
to be honest,
I think it's funny.
I don't really know.
I'm not much of a,
you know,
I maybe said this before,
I'm not much of a people person,
you know,
in doing my blog.
It's one of the few places where being
incredibly selfish,
it's actually very positive.
Um,
because I'm not really,
when I'm taking a picture of someone,
like I don't really put their names
down,
rarely do I put the people's names down
because it's just not that important,
you know,
I'm taking a picture of someone.
It's my perception of who they are.
I'm taking it by the way I'm taking it
because it's some I want to be able to
look at.
I want to enjoy the picture.
So it's my selfishness that's actually
very generous in the sense that,
you know,
I share the picture,
I'm trying to take a nice picture of
them,
but I'm doing it for totally selfish
reasons.
And one of the things I think people
misunderstand on the blog is just
because I take a picture of someone,
it doesn't mean they have great personal
style.
I mean,
I don't know these people,
most of them I've never met before.
Um,
you know,
maybe there's just one thing and the
look that I really love and that's all I
want to focus on and I try and shoot it
in a way that highlights that.
But,
uh,
you know,
I don't really have a lot of people and
I'm just not judgmental that way and I
think that sincerity comes through in
the blog.
I mean,
to me it really doesn't matter who they
are.
It's not that I don't want to shoot
people in Hollywood or models or
musicians,
uh,
if I ran into 20 musicians in a row,
then I'll look great,
I'd shoot them.
But that just rarely ever happens.
I don't really fall into that.
But,
uh,
it's for me,
it's much,
much more abstract.
Yeah.
I think,
uh,
Tony Randall on the odd couple always
looked great.
I always thought he looked really cool.
I don't think Jay fashion's really
changed much in the last five years.
I mean,
the system is the system,
um,
if it was really going to change in a
major way,
now would have been the time to do it.
You know,
so many companies are closing,
but they're not really changing their
method of how they do it.
They're jumping on the new hot thing,
whatever it is right now.
It's blogs,
you know,
who knows what's gonna,
be next holograms or whatever.
Um,
and I think a lot of companies are
closing,
which is great.
I think we're way too oversaturated,
too many brands,
too many stores,
too many labels.
Um,
so,
you know,
if it was going to change now would be
the time to do it.
But it's not really changing that much.
Shipping's not changing,
you know,
I'd love to see a,
a time when,
you know,
when it actually gets cold is when
winter clothes hit the store,
you know,
as opposed to the winter clothes hit the
store always on the hottest day in
August is when all the winter clothes
hit.
So I think um,
because of technology and because of
this kind of speed of digital,
uh,
digital internet and everything,
it will change soon because smart
designers,
young designers are going to be able to
start showing their collection in a much
wider audience and ship those products
closer to the real time.
They won't need vogue and all these
other places.
They have to work so far in advance to
promote their fashion because they'll be
able to do it right.
You know themselves through the
Internet,
right to their audience.
And be able to,
um,
uh,
ship the close accordingly to that
audience.
You know,
I think there's very,
a day very soon where you'll be able to
get some kind of digital printout of
your body and have the clothes made for
your shape.
There'll be a new age of tailoring and
um,
you know,
it's definitely more than five years
off,
but I don't think it's a really far
away.
You know,
I think it's definitely in the near
future and that will really change
fashion,
the fashion system,
uh,
in the sense that,
you know,
you won't just have all this excess of
clothes and things shift so early
because you need x amount of time to
sell.
Hopefully it'll become much more
efficient,
much more effective if you're actually
making clothes that fit people in
clothes that people are ordering and
want as opposed to trying to guess what
they might want my readers or are
located a everywhere.
You know,
one of the things that I knew about
doing a photo driven blog was that you
didn't have to read English to be able
to enjoy the photographs.
You know,
there were elements of people that are
looking at it for the fashion content.
There is an element of people that kind
of like to live vicariously through all
these different crazy places.
I'm going,
there's an element that likes to share
their fashion idea.
Maybe,
you know,
they had always dreamed of becoming a
fashion designer and moving to New York
or Milan,
but for whatever reason,
a family reason or whatever,
they weren't able to do that.
So they're stuck in Wisconsin or
wherever they are.
And this is their chance to kind of be
in that community a little bit,
share their comments,
look at fashion,
share it with an,
with an audience.
One of the things we're very proud of is
we've been able to create an audience
that's respectful that,
you know,
you can talk about your fashion ideas,
what you like,
what you don't like in a respectful for
them.
Um,
so with that said,
I think it's a,
it's all over the place.
I mean,
all I know is right now when I travel
and I do these book tours,
know we always get a really,
really good turnout.
And a very,
a very varied audience,
you know,
men,
women,
young,
old,
rich,
poor.
I'm the audience.
Very much looks like,
uh,
like the,
photographs of my blog photographs in my
book,
which is something I'm very proud of.
New York has changed,
changed a lot,
you know,
I've been here almost 20 years.
And uh,
maybe when I first moved here,
people have said I'd be a horrible place
to raise kids.
And now I think everyone would agree
it's pretty good place to raise kids.
It's clean.
It's a,
a modern.
I mean,
I travel around a lot and um,
I still think New York looks great,
you know what I mean?
All the time.
There's new buildings going up,
new.
It's different kinds of architecture.
Um,
there's just always something happening.
So I hate to sound like such a Yankees
Fan.
That's such a New York fan.
But,
uh,
I still can't think of anywhere else I'd
rather live than here.
Shoot from the heart.
That's a good one.
I think that actually just stopped at
that shoot from the heart.
I think,
um,
would be the best year I think.
Um,
it really doesn't matter,
you know,
I like to take good quality photographs.
I'd like to try and have the light a
certain way and the person's standards
certainly,
even though it's all very natural,
it happens very quickly.
I worked very quickly and work with what
I'm given.
Um,
I don't really pose the people or
anything.
I just kind of worked with who I think
that person is.
But what I think I'm the honesty of it
is I think people like to live
vicariously.
I mean it's the whole idea of this
reality TV.
They like to live vicariously through
other people and see other people's
ideas and other people's take on the
world.
So whether you're taking it with just a
little digital camera,
if you're actually taking pictures that
mean something to you in a real way and
you actually have something to say,
people will follow that blog,
you know,
because you'll find likeminded people.
Um,
but by doing that,
I think one of the things that separates
me is,
you know,
I don't shoot just all 20 year old
hipsters,
you know,
old and young and,
and that,
that brand comes across in the variety
of people I shoot because I actually
have something to say and I can do that
as opposed to saying one thing over and
over.
It gives me a wider vocabulary to be
able to shoot people in a lot of
different ways and a lot of different
types of people.
But you always know it's one of my shots
and that's because you to take it very
seriously.
And uh,
and I have a real passionate about,
I have a real point of view.
And uh,
so I think,
you know,
that's what someone has to do before
just deciding that I think I want to go
out and take pictures of people on the
street and like they really have to have
a point of view.
You know,
it's very important what I don't shoot
as opposed to what I do.
Shoot.
There's a lot of people in the fashion
business I've never shot.
Um,
so without a,
a real passionate point of view,
I don't think there's anything you can
do because then it just becomes a,
a report on product and there's a lot of
blogs like that and I think they're
incredibly boring,
you know,
just a report of what's out there,
doesn't do anything for me.
Well,
passion and a point of view,
number one,
consistency.
You know,
you have to be able to create a
consistent voice because if you're
blogging in a real way,
you know,
uh,
I think you have to do it very
regularly.
If it's not five days a week or six days
a week in a way that people start to
know when they can come see your blog,
um,
when there's going to be new images up
that always doesn't have to be exactly
the same time every day.
You know,
it's not so bad to keep them guessing.
That's so bad to have him coming back
once or twice,
but there has to be consistency in the
voice because you just can't fake it
five days a week.
Um,
so I think that's really important.
Uh,
I think next generation of blogs,
it's going to be just like the beginning
of what websites,
you know,
you could kind of do it on your own and
kind of habit and it didn't look great
necessarily,
but now,
you know,
blogs are getting very sophisticated and
uh,
I think people are going to have to
really start to be serious about the way
the blog looks.
That's,
you know,
the days I think of,
um,
just being able to steal images from all
over the place to put them on your blog
and just putting another two cents in on
somebody else's conversation.
It's pretty close to over because the
blog is not gonna be able to grow that
way.
The blog is only going to be able to
grow once you're in control of all the
content.
And like that's why street style blogs
have grown so quickly is,
you know,
we're in control of the visuals were in
control of the writing.
You know,
if you're using a particular kind of
blog,
you can be more in control of the ponds
and the graphics and everything else.
I don't know,
you can't really do anything.
Yeah,
I mean,
at least for me anyway,
because I'm,
you know,
it's so many different things.
You know what I mean?
It's the clothes themselves,
it's the person.
Uh,
it's,
uh,
I just have to,
you know,
that's the artist,
there's no,
I wish I could say as a marketer,
you know,
if you're wearing this brand and blah,
blah,
that will make it really interesting,
but it's not,
you know,
that's the artist in me,
sometimes you meet someone and it's just
something that clicks,
you know,
and it might be an obvious kind of
beauty or a non obvious kind of beauty
or just something that you feel,
you know,
I shut this woman in,
I'm in Barcelona the other day,
this beautiful older woman and she,
you know,
really beautifully aged face and very
perfectly done hair and fur coat.
And um,
she was definitely not typical
traditional beauty,
but there was just something so charming
about her and I don't think she'd ended
up on anybody else's blog,
but you know,
that that is definitely part of my
vocabulary.
And I'm sure she didn't get up that day
thinking,
what should I wear to be shocked by the
Sartorialist I know he's in town.
Um,
but,
you know,
that's the fun of it.
You know,
you just never know.
There are people I see all the time that
you would think,
you know,
maybe be on the blog,
but if I don't feel something and don't
feel that I'm going to be able to shoot
it the way that I want,
then it doesn't really matter.
But all black is pretty boring.
You're going gonna do all black.
You better do some good proportion or
texture or something like that.
Color pattern,
things like that.
That actually real elements of design
are always a good one.
Good place to start.
My heroes are my mom and dad.
Um,
and uh,
I think just anyone that succeeds at
what they do through really trying to do
something unique and difference and uh,
interesting something that maybe not the
people told them would never work.
But that's um,
you know,
really,
says something about who they are and
how they saw something differently.
And,
uh,
and it's a bunch of different things,
you know,
the guys that do the Mac computers,
that design for the Mac computers I
think are great.
I don't know if they'd be a hero,
but someone I definitely look up to,
you know,
take that chance of saying,
we're going to do them in color now.
And then knowing as someone that used to
work in the fashion business,
how tough that is to go to the stores
and say we want you to buy these
computers in color now and that they're
going to come back and say,
oh,
how are you going to buy?
I don't know what color,
what percentage,
but what color and what computer and all
of that.
Some that has such a passion for
something and is willing to really,
um,
go through all the steps and be able to
sell that concept to somebody.
Um,
you know,
whether it's designing the Mac computer,
whether it's Armani and the eighties,
you know,
doing completely different kinds of
design for women.
Whether it's,
um,
Bruce Weber kind of figuring out how to
shoot people in a wholesome but sexy
way,
you know,
those are the people that look at that.
I think I'm most inspired by in terms of
their work,
an ethical dilemma.
Um,
I don't think it was an ethical dilemma,
but I did have to figure out how I would
handle having advertising on the blog
because I knew that there would be
certain people saying,
oh,
well,
you know,
here it goes,
blogs are going to go downhill because
they're gonna have advertising and
they're just going to shoot him.
American apparel was one of the first
advertisers on the site.
And I was prepared for people to start
saying,
no,
now we're going to start seeing a lot of
American apparel or whatever.
But that never happened.
You know,
I think the sincerity and the integrity
of the blog,
the fact that,
um,
I was able to have advertising and it's
never affected any of the work on the
site that you never see anything about
American apparel on the site.
Unless it's something that I see in
someone happens to be wearing American
apparel that didn't.
Absolute integrity and sincerity is
still there.
I just shot a big story for Berberi big
ad campaign and I announced it because I
was very proud of the work and showed
some of the pictures I really liked from
that project.
And uh,
probably did three or four posts,
but I didn't put anything in there
about,
you know,
where to buy the trenches,
no information about it.
I was just showing the photographs I was
very proud of from that project.
And the audience totally understood it,
you know,
they,
um,
but at the same time,
I love burberry and that was very happy
to work with that.
And I think the new reality is sometimes
people have a hard time handling.
The new reality is,
you know,
um,
uh,
you know,
I'm an artist and I'm a,
um,
I guess,
you know,
that's the only way you could say it.
I don't really consider myself a
journalist.
I'm not trying to sell you something.
I'm not trying to tell you the story of
these things.
I'm just showing you my pictures,
so I feel totally comfortable saying I
love burberry or Ralph Lauren or
whatever because uh,
those are things that I like and um,
so that's know that's hard for some
people to be able to understand that,
but because it's so consistent and I've
been so consistent in how I present
those things and how I let them be
manifest themselves on the blog,
that's what I think has been able to
keep the sincerity and keep the
audience.
I'm believing in what I do.
The worst career advice.
Uh,
I don't know.
I've never really had much career
advice.
My Dad always gave me great advice and
um,
you know,
I think,
uh,
I mean,
I hate to say it,
but,
you know,
I wasn't a good corporate person.
They know everything that,
uh,
made me horrible.
Working in incorporation was perfect for
this kind of job.
So,
uh,
I never really got bad advice because I
never really asked for any think it'd be
maybe like Pablo Picasso.
I think he was probably crazy.
I mean,
I know he was crazy.
I think everyone says he was crazy.
So I think you just wouldn't know what
would happen at dinner and I'd love to
talk to them about art and how he
challenged himself and was always trying
to look for a new way of expressing his
artistic,
uh,
his artistic expression or whatever.
But,
uh,
I think he also would probably do
something crazy at dinner in and that
would be fun.
Maybe him and Tracy Morgan,
the fact that,
uh,
I always thought I knew better than the
people I was working for.
That's not good.
That's not a good thing to think that
you always know better than the people
that your bosses and and always create a
problem for me.
I always thought I had a good point of
view on this,
that and whatever.
And it turned out to be okay.
But,
you know,
at some point,
you always created problems for me
working corporately.
And uh,
so at some point my dad said,
you know,
we can't always be them at some point.
It's got to be you.
You're the only thing that's consistent
in this and that's hard.
You don't want to hear that from your
dad.
Um,
but I know was probably true and I think
it helped me realize that either I got
to put up or shut up and uh,
and so I'm glad that's when I went out
and worked on my own.
I don't have all the answers,
but,
you know,
I really had to push myself to handle
all the different areas,
you know,
because it's not just photography,
it's running the business and its
accounting,
all these different kinds of things.
So,
you know,
now I have,
I have,
um,
the challenge of actually trying to go
out there and learn a lot of different
things to make it all keep going.